[Música]
hola
hoy quiero contarles que dirijo un
programa de divulgación en torno a la
ingeniería y la matemática
pero necesito primero confesarles algo
cuando yo estaba en el colegio odiaba
las matemáticas no lo mío era lenguaje
historia y desde el primero medio tenía
súper claro que yo quería estudiar
periodismo
era una estudiante que le iba bien en
todo tenía altas calificaciones e
incluso en aquellas materias que odiaba
como matemáticas
también me iba bastante bien en ciencias
e incluso recuerdo una profesora que me
insistía y me insistía con que yo debía
estudiar algo relacionado con ciencias
pero yo no me veía en esa yo no me
imaginaba estudiando la misma bacteria o
la misma célula por años y años y años
no yo quería aventura yo quería
descubrir cosas y darlas a conocer al
mundo y para mí en ese entonces la
ciencia no me daba esa oportunidad
y que decirles con respecto a carreras
relacionadas con ingeniería matemática y
tecnología de esas ni siquiera busquen
información cuando iba a ingresar a la
universidad
debo decirles que una de las razones no
la única por supuesto pero una de las
razones por las cuales estudié
periodismo es porque no tenía
matemáticas
y con el tiempo pensé porque odiaba las
quien me habían hecho de malo a mí
y la pregunta viene que viene acá es
como una periodista que odiaba las
matemáticas llega a dirigir un programa
de divulgación en torno a la ingeniería
y la matemática y sigue siendo feliz
y es que la vida me dio algunas
oportunidades interesantes que pude
tomar una de ellas fue cuando hice mi
práctica profesional y me quedé
trabajando un par de años en una
productora que desarrollaba diversos
programas de televisión en torno a la
ciencia
y para mí fue un detonante me enamoré de
esta mezcla de la ciencia del periodismo
entonces a partir de ese momento yo dije
soy periodista científica esto es lo mío
incluso me asocia la chispa la
asociación chilena de periodistas
científicos
y tuve que investigar temas de
biotecnología de biología de psiquiatría
de neurología pero no me tocó nada de
ingeniería ni matemáticas menos mal
y en esos años me llegó una oferta de
trabajo interesante
donde un centro de investigación
necesitaba una periodista científica
entonces abrí el mail para ver los
detalles y me asusté cuando vi el nombre
de la institución que convocaba
se llamaba institutos sistemas complejos
de ingeniería y lo voy a repetir porque
es un nombre un poco largo
institutos sistemas complejos de
ingeniería
inmediatamente a cerra el mail y dije
esto no es para mí
sin embargo me quedó dando vueltas en la
cabeza si es que en realidad existía
algún periodista especializado en
ingeniería o especializado en ingeniería
compleja
entonces pensé que mis colegas debían
estar en la misma que yo así es que me
ate me postulé y llevo ya 12 años
trabajando en el instituto sistemas
complejos de ingeniería
efe
y al principio así como yo no sabía nada
de ingeniería él y si no sabían nada de
comunicación de la ciencia
y el financista de ese entonces que era
la iniciativa científica milenio le
había dicho a este centro de
investigación que necesitaba desarrollar
actividades en torno a la educación
divulgación audit extensión y todos los
nombres que se le dan a este tipo de
actividades
entonces dije tengo una misión por donde
parto
entonces empecé a mirar qué hacían estos
investigadores asociados a este centro
quien investigaban
y me encontré con un abanico de áreas me
encontré con transporte con energía con
ciudad
y tuve que leer papers papers que tenía
matemáticas
fue difícil
pero rápidamente me interesé por una
investigación aplicada que encontré y vi
que el calendario del fútbol chileno de
primera división era desarrollado por
modelos matemáticos de los
investigadores asociados a este centro
es decir cuando jugaba el colo colo con
la universidad de chile y en quien lugar
no era por sorteo no se ponían de
acuerdo los clubes era una herramienta
matemática la que daba solución a este
problema un problema que era bastante
complejo
entonces empecé a mirar qué más podía
encontrar y vi cómo los modelos
matemáticas podrían decirme dónde
localizar de mejor manera los hospitales
o dónde poner las escuelitas rurales que
se habían caído después del terremoto
del año 2010 o cómo hacer que los
bomberos lleguen más rápido a las
emergencias disminuyendo así por ejemplo
la pérdida de material y de vidas
entonces sentí que había encontrado oro
porque así como estas investigaciones
aplicadas me habían interesado a mí que
era una persona que no le gustaban las
matemáticas imaginen lo que podía lograr
en los colegios
y fue así como fuimos armando un
proyecto
que debía tomar estas investigaciones
aplicadas trabajarlas con un equipo y
desarrollar productos que fueran
interesantes para los colegios así nace
comunidad ingenio mi hija
que quiere aportar a la educación y
definió su campo de acción en la
enseñanza media con los estudiantes y
con sus profesores de matemáticas
desarrollamos diversas actividades pero
el eje central la columna vertebral de
este proyecto es la capacitación a
profesores
ellos nuestros profesores de matemáticas
son nuestra alma sin ellos no hacemos
nada
y cada año abrimos nuevos cupos para que
nuevos profesores se inserten en esta
red pasen por cursos donde nosotros les
enseñamos a utilizar estos recursos
educativos y le damos a conocer una
propuesta metodológica y son ellos
mismos quienes aplican esto en sus
colegios
y en sus salas de clases
y durante este tiempo hemos capacitado a
más de 600 profesores y gracias a ellos
hemos llegado a más de 14.000
estudiantes de manera efectiva y
comprobable
pero
a quien le entregamos a estos profesores
pues les entregamos problemas si
problemas problemas que abordan
distintas temáticas como el transporte
público la programación de semáforos el
diseño de un diario el calendario del
fútbol chileno entre otras y cada uno de
esos temas tiene asociado un un par de
recursos educativos que son tangibles
que son motivantes que están en torno a
la indagación y en distintos formatos
tales como casos de estudio guías
materiales recortables juegos de mesa
legos vídeos entre otros todos en el
ámbito de la indagación con tal de
fomentar la creatividad del estudiante
también tenemos diversas actividades
complementarias que van sumando a esta
capacitación de profesores llevamos a
los estudiantes a la universidad estamos
en diversas universidades y les decimos
sean ingenieros por un día
también hacemos seminarios realizamos
charlas en investigadores y en colegios
y para estudiantes de enseñanza media
desarrollamos cursos algunos de ellos
enfocados en temas de género
también tenemos este concurso entre
otros
si sólo tomamos en cuenta estas
actividades complementarias la cantidad
de personas que ha pasado por ellas
suma más de 19 mil personas en los
últimos cinco años
y no sólo estamos en santiago también
tenemos un campo de acción permanente en
la región del bío bío y en diversas
regiones de chile
pero como nos diferenciamos de una clase
de matemática tradicional y es que
nosotros proponemos hacer las cosas al
revés
lo que habitualmente se estila es
presentar primero la fórmula y después
si se alcanza el tiempo desarrollarlo en
un problema
en cambio nosotros decimos vamos con el
problema primero qué opinan de que saben
de cómo lo resolverían solo con sus
conocimientos previos
es la invitación que le hacemos a los
estudiantes por ejemplo en el tema de
transporte quien no tiene una opinión
frente al transporte público
o alguna experiencia o alguna idea de
cómo mejorarlo
y es aquí donde entran los materiales
tangibles como un juego de mesa o en el
caso del transporte les pasamos un plano
de la ciudad donde pueden dibujar que
recorridos debería hacer el transporte
público según los estudiantes
y vamos complejizando dificultando este
problema a tal punto que el estudiante
con sus conocimientos previos ya no
pueda resolverlo y sea él mismo el que
dice necesito más herramientas necesito
matemáticas
y la matemática aparece por una
necesidad es decir tiene un sentido una
utilidad y esto es tremendamente bien
recepcionado por los estudiantes
como dije no ya tiene diez años más de
diez años
y en todo este tiempo en este trayecto
les puedo decir que yo ya no odio las
matemáticas todo lo contrario me parecen
tremendamente interesante lo mismo que
la ingeniería
y me hice la pregunta en algún momento
si yo cuando estaba en el colegio
hubiese participado en un proyecto como
como un ingenio hubiese estudiado
ingeniería
no lo sé es así o quizás no
pero al menos hubiese tenido la
información para decidir
porque decidir con información es uno de
los pilares de común ingenio
queremos mostrarle a los estudiantes la
utilidad de la matemática y que después
decir
esta evelyn adulta ya se sigue
encantando con este proyecto porque a
través de él puede buscar a estas evelyn
es a estas niñas y niños que están en
los colegios y que rechazan la
matemática únicamente por no encontrar
las útiles
y cuando pienso en nuevos proyectos en
nuevas ideas para este programa trato de
siempre conectarme con mi infancia y con
mi adolescencia porque este rechazo sea
la matemática sigue existiendo no es
distinto en esta generación
comunidad ingenio ha recibido premios
recibió muy buenas evaluaciones
adjudicados fondos concursables ha
llegado a cientos de profesores y miles
de estudiantes en prácticamente todo el
chile pero yo siento que ninguno de esos
es mi mayor logro como directora de este
proyecto
para mí mi mayor orgullo mi hija
anaís
de 18 años a punto de entrar a la
universidad y adivinen que quiere
estudiar
ingeniería
creo que me lleve trabajo y pasión para
la casa
quisiera dejarlos con algunas
reflexiones
una de ellas tiene que ver con que
piensen si hay algo que cuando ustedes
estaban en el colegio no les gustaba o
rechazaban y ahora que son adultos
quizás si les darían una oportunidad
y por qué
y cambio
también invitarlos a mirar a su
alrededor y ver si niños niñas y jóvenes
pidiéndoles una potencialidad por un
área no quieren acercarse a ellas porque
la encuentran aburrida porque no le ven
la utilidad porque no tienen información
los invito a crear oportunidades los
invito a tomar esas oportunidades a dar
información a apoyar a nuestros
profesores porque de esa manera las
nuevas generaciones podrán tomar
decisiones de manera más informada
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]